We have 35, the number of which is 3,
that is, it's the same 30, three,
1 tenth, 2 tenth and 3rd tier group of 10,
and also have 5, which is a unit of units written,
means we have 5 points. Look
one, two, three, four, five.
Now I want three of these 35's
and add 6 points to 5 points.
These six points are written in the order of the units,
Look at one, two, three, four, five and six points.
And I advise you to stop the video
and try it yourself on 35 to 6.
So, let's just think about it.
I'll start from the order of units.
We have 5 points and we want to add 6 points.
What will happen together?
Very good, 5 points plus 6 points, which will get 11 points
and we still have these three top ten
will remain 3 dozens and 11 points.
Let me write it.
Now we have a little problem as I can not
double digit number
category of units.
If not, this number is not 311,
It's three tens and 11 points,
verb now how to group or move this number,
so I can only get a double digit.
We have zero, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight
and nine, here, instead of a double digit, we can write 1 point.
Can I group and say?
"Look, I can quote these points as a dozen"
because I have 10 points, then
I can group them together
and make a group of 10s.
Let me explain again what we did.
I took 10, these ten points
and I just wrote them together
in one group.
So, what will happen to us now?
We have already got it after the grouping
one, two, three, four, four.
And how many points will we have now?
In the fourteen we have grouped 10 points,
and only 1 point left us.
So, this can be written as 4 points plus 1 point.
Remember, we had 3 dozens and 11 points,
which resulted in fourteen and one points.
And let me write it like this,
as 1 unit and 4 dozens.
And how do we get the answer?
if this picture was not.
You can actually group
Doing so in your mind,
but there is another option. Can you say that?
"Very well, we have 5 plus 6, which is equal to 11 points."
but I can not write these 11 in the order of units,
That is why it is the same,
what 10 plus 1, one ten plus plus 1.
Often they say that 5 out of 6 are equal to 11,
just remember 1, but in reality:
Remember that 5 out of 6 is equal to 1 dozen and one units.
And those 11 numbers,
he has a category of heights of 1 and
The unit of units also has 1 point.
And as a result, we make the tens of each other,
1 dozens plus 3 dozens will be fourteen.
But I really want you to understand,
it is not necessary to mechanically say that 5 of the 6 guesses are equal to 11,
but rather it is 1 point and 1 point
and that's why we are writing this tenth of the categories.
And it turns out to be a grouping.
We rolled up dozens.
I took these 10 points,
and I can make them a dozen,
from which I get the tenth of the order 1.
the remaining 1 point in the rankings.